bah on vient 3g vous qu'il y ait de
pâques capuche ne faut trop d'écho notez
bien sur vos droits
nous attendons à passer
il manque un
[Musique]
et voilà le défaire parce que ça une
bonne brioche en fumant vraiment
imagination tu nous as déjà fait une
brioche il ya trois jours
papa partait de parts pata pata départ
puisqu'elle fait dans mon atelier une
tarte au cloud elle casse peut-être au
bout la brioche
[Musique]
entre deux gâteaux grève qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'elle ne
veut plus faire de gâteaux pâtes à tarte
tu te mets en grève vraiment est
définitivement plus de pâtisserie self
il dit radieux date millefeuille et
brioches
moi je vais au ciné mois au cinéma nous
occupez vous du dîner
j'espère qu'il sera bon je ne suis pas
faire la cuisine mais je vais faire un
gâteau et je vais d'abord me faire un
très joli petit abusé de pâtissière
[Musique]
oui
en finir
[Musique]
je suis très ému c'est mon premier
gâteau il va sûrement être très bon
alors tous les marques françaises année
[Musique]
ok
voici ce hiatus vous savez rien je vais
arranger ça ratha olalalala ans tu n'as
pas ta cloud or quoi nous le petit mon
pauvre et nous décourageons pas il doit
y avoir une erreur dans les proportions
je recommence
[Musique]
e
on n'entend rien c'est plutôt bon signe
tu crois oui bonsoir tout le monde 500
drôle ça sent le gâteau n'y a pas que
toi qui sache faire la cuisine en gâteau
pas qu'y a t'il d'extraordinaire pâte à
tarte
pourquoi ces terres et au nez et à rien
quelle drôle d'odeur crime en fait mon
âme dont
[Musique]
non
cette bourse
j'en reprends il est bien meilleur qu'au
lit maintenant tu laisses aura pour
comment peuvent-elles manger ça
houlot le coût du malade il est très
mauvaise nous ratons moi j'arrête la
grève demain je retourne à mes fourneaux
du ve vous ferez une brioche combien
croyez-vous qu'il y ait de papus neuf
autres ont été portées bien sûr photo
témoin aura pas de recours attention il
nous manque un
[Musique]